hey let's go bro Spanish so I saw
megaminx
playing this game and I'm like yep I
need to check it out right now
an emu so any moon sits 7 a.m. waking up
in the morning gotta be fresh gotta go
downstairs gotta have my ball hey might
look at my friends hey it's my friends
how are you
yes we're friends best friends I love
everyone so happy
hey yo shelf it up oh god oh god what's
going on I am doing it what's happening
what is in my heart broken I can't take
selfies when I'm heartbroken got it they
talked to you for a moment uh seduced
gossip threatened what you're just gonna
stand by sorry never mind
oh okay then so this might all this is
my love this is my senpai senpai save I
smile senpai I love you I love you
senpai oh look it's mica mica oh damn
damn titties what a great time in school
makes really make me miss my time in
school you're so good so great I don't
need to take off my shoes because I
don't need shoes cuz I'm I want somebody
to notice me and simp I never notice
twos simply notice quality and I'm
quality let's go to our classroom we
can't relate for our school that would
be just crazy oh my god what the [ __ ] is
going on Kawai
I hope you guys are enjoying your
lockers look at that side boob Jesus
Christ that's a side boob right [ __ ]
there
my smoking a [ __ ] cigar and have
giant tits best game ever ten out of ten
IGN thank you
okay okay okay all right you got me
I'm waited out you got me that is that I
[ __ ] did I spawn a Titan I was trying
to learn the controls and I think I spy
spawn a Titan midnight I whip it what
what why oh oh oh
hey how you doing that's right
miku-chan don't worry about a mika-chan
uh she asked for it she started it
she started it don't worry about it some
pie somebody I did it for you
I love you chef Mike will you please
just notice me I love him so much
will do anything like that bye why would
it no it is big love you said by
sherbert it's in pain simpe chipper
tempeh loves you okay so we have to
murder people and sacrifice them to
senpai got it got it
let's get the scissors that's nothing
weird with scissor right anyone has a
scissor
ooh is that it is that a mop oh yeah all
we need to burn them in the furnace and
we get ha ha ha ha yes I mean I should
be weirded out and I should just say
that the game is [ __ ] up but goddamn
it's beautiful hey nice haircut
eh oh that's rat yeah no one suspects a
thing
ok [ __ ] needs to go in the furnace a
dump dump er in the furnace Whip It Up
video there you go
I'm a [ __ ] activate and [ __ ] is gone
and she's gone let's carry this
we must not the flows look at what I'm
doing for you sir pie I murdered someone
for you that's how much I love you all
right we can murder her I guess
great how nice
ah we can't dump the body yet all right
that's fine
should probably get a new outfit
there we go Sam pie murder floor mopping
simulator 2015 best game ever game of
the year
it's so deep she's doing weird twitches
ohh oh my god Oh a toast an actual
toaster yes no no no no no Mike please
please Sam I'm right here
please simp I have this toast please
will you have this chose with me I'm
scared scared
it's an early feel of a game but it's
[ __ ] weird but wait is good right I
enjoyed it because it's different and
it's awesome so don't murder people let
me just put that disclaimer there
actually do whatever you want just don't
sue me for it that okay great maybe like
you enjoyed this video Bros I'm sure you
did I saw you and I'll see you present
next one as always stay awesome brush
how did I do that
oh my god fabulous fabulous fabulous
fabulous